if we stick on
uh hitler for just a minute uh what
lessons do you take from that time do
you think it's a
unique moment in human history that
world war
ii i mean both stalin and hitler
you know is is it something that's just
an outlier in all of humans history in
terms of the atrocities
or is there uh the lessons to be learned
you mentioned we mentioned offline that
you're
not just a student of the entirety of
the history but you're also fascinated
by just different like
policies and stuff like what's the
immigration policy what's the policy on
science and
third reich and power let me plug it by
richard richard evans i think
is what it was because that actually
will tell you like what was it like to
live under the nazi regime
without the war yeah um yeah it's a hard
question
in terms of the lessons that we can
learn because there's a lot and it's
actually been
over it's been over indexed almost
everything comes back to hitler in a
conversation so i kind of think of it
within mao stalin and hitler
as i don't want to say payments for
but like the end point
payment for the sins and the problems
of the monarchical system that evolve
within europe
basically like 1400 and more i basically
think that
1400 the wars between the state you know
wars between france
england the balance of power eventually
world war one and then
serfdom within russia the russian
revolution that birthed stalin
same thing the kaiser and imperial
germany and this like incredibly
crazy system of balance of power in
world war one
and then same thing within china in
terms of the warring states and then
the disintegration the european you know
how this is how they think of it you
know
which is like the century of humiliation
and they had to have
something like this i think of it i try
to think of it within the context of
that
i don't want to think of i don't want to
sound like an inevitabilist
but i think of it as i like to think
about systems
especially in here in dc that's why i
got into politics which is that
you have to understand systems of power
and the incentives within systems
and the disincentives and the downside
risk of what your purp of what you're
creating
because it that is what leads and
creates
the behavior within that system i was
just talking to my girlfriend about this
yesterday it's kind of funny like
i read these i'm obsessed with these
books um by robert carro the biographies
of lyndon johnson he's written like 5
000 pages so far and it's still not done
okay so like these are these are like
books i base my life on
and look these are washington and the
story of the post-new deal era and
forward
not much has changed like the senate is
the still the senate
so many of the same problems with the
senate are still there um
in some cases no not not anymore but for
a while
some of the people who were there with
johnson are actually still um
one of them is the president of the
united states just a joke and
you think about also same with the media
relationship right like there's this
media really
they may have come and gone like the the
people who were in the media
and who were cozy with the
administration officials
i mean they just recreated themselves
it's like this it's like an ecosystem
which doesn't change and the that's why
i'm like
oh it's not that was a specific time
that's just dc
like that is dc because
of the way the system is architected
it's pretty much been that way since
like
1908 whenever like you know teddy
roosevelt was dining with these
journalists and he would yell at them
and then he would go over to
the society house and like in many ways
that's now instead of going to henry
adams's house
like the people are congregating in
calorama
um which is the richest neighborhood
here at somebody else's house like it's
the same
thing so you have to think about the
system and then the incentives within
that system
about what the outcomes that they're
producing if you actually want to think
about
how can i change this from the outside
that's also why it's very difficult to
change
because the system is designed in order
to produce
actually pretty specific outcomes that
can only be changed in extraordinary
times
yeah it's sometimes hard to to predict
what kind
of outcomes will result from the
incentive uh
the system that you create right right
in the case because especially when it's
novel
kind of situations what trump actually
created a pretty novel situation
and a lot of the
things that we've seen in the 20th
century were very novel systems where
people were very optimistic about the
the outcomes right and then it turned
out to not
have the results that they predicted
you